jean le poulain je suis content que ce
soit et quoi parce que tu es tu veux
partie de ma vie
bien que je les ai connus quand j'étais
très jeune tu l'étais aussi et je ne
peux pas te regarder ou pensé à toi sans
dissocier roberge jacques charon
jacquier scandèrent chazot chazot marque
deux buts et marc denis qui étaient les
mousquetaires du rire de la bonne humeur
de la vie et du travail parce que on
oublie souvent que ceux qui nous font
rire et qui nous amusent et qui ont une
imagination
une invention quelquefois génial au
souvent folle nous ça demande beaucoup
beaucoup de travail et surtout la métier
un métier parce que le théâtre c'est
vrai que c'est une famille mais vous
étiez comme les cinq doigts de la main
alors évidemment il y en a deux de
disparus heureusement robert rien je
joue encore pierre mandello et toi
agents
j'ai vu que j'avais signé 60 mise en
scène de théâtre que tu as pas arrêté de
jouer depuis très longtemps et là tu es
société à la coller française depuis
1981 car tu en france est 30 18 70 des
sociétés 3,78 et et société en 79 avant
d'obtenir un an avant un an après ses
très rares un d'être sociétaires c'est
assez rare enfin c'est tout même
maintenant plus dans les usages
oui roland bertin et hénanbihen week
allemand après oudin dans ah oui elle
était plus sérieuse et sévère et un
vieux rêve ça j'en entraînerai c'est un
vieux rêve oui lorsque j'étais au
conservatoire de toulouse
j'ai décidé dès le départ des rentrées
la comédie française d'être pour la
comédie française à paris de se monter
dans ce but là j'ai fait mes études j'ai
eu mon premier prix et on n'a pas voulu
de moi ça a été une grosse déception je
crois que c'est une des plus grandes de
ma vie de ma carrière
enfin je me suis attelé pendant une
trentaine d'années à jouer sur le
boulevard et 30 ans a prévenu quand on
conduit jouer sur les boulevards et
quand je vois que tu as joué claudel
pour des faits de giraudoux achard
musset salacrou et combien d'autres
quelques boulevards c'est pour toi c'est
comme avait il y avait toujours quelque
part des textes classe
ah oui ça sûrement sur moi j'ai beaucoup
de jus monte de grands spectacles super
vienne audiberti laub route notamment
claudel la tâche et le pain dur enfin je
n'ai pas citer tous mais c'était du
théâtre des reliques de cdd de langue du
verbe avons tous et anouilh tu as fait
confiance et un beau coup on l'a joué la
grotte les quadrilles et puis j'ai monté
sur l'adaptation de la nuit des rois
avec suzanne flou qui a été un énorme
succès et qu'on la joue plus de 400 fois
au vieux colombier je crois que c'était
un des derniers spectacles et quelques
voix on reproche au théâtre français je
parle de d'accueil or on va en parler
avec jean pierre vincent qui va piano
voix
on dit bon est ce que dans un théâtre
qui est interne est de tradition
on doit respecter les textes classiques
où on doit protéger le patrimoine de la
littérature qui est très important est
ce que on a créé ce cas des jeunes
auteurs est ce que est ce que ça c'est
important est ce que par exemple moi je
me sens de but depuis 30 ans que je fais
ce métier il ya très peu d'acteurs que
j'ai vue révélée par la cohérence et
d'acteurs si on peut dire quand même
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de comédiens qui
aurait été révélée à la
comédie-française dont robert hirsch
aujourd'hui avec la manne immense acteur
vous avez des manneliers duchaussoy des
michel aumont qui sont les comédiens de
première de première mais seulement il
n'a pas été révélée plus par le cm1 que
par oui mais c'était quand même la
comédie française qu'il acquit là qu'il
a sorti quelque sorte
et s'il y avait de grands comédiens la
comédie française autrefois il ya
maintenant aussi de grands comédiens
mais faisons qui non plus par le fait
même de l'évolution de la vie des médias
et pas de la télévision du cinéma qui a
pris une importance considérable
ils n'ont plus les possibilités
évidemment de se faire valoir comme le
faisait autrefois les comédiens qu'il
n'avait pas la rivalité
ça va du cinéma ou la télévision mais
pas sks que des jeunes docteurs ont été
déjà l'auteur il y en a pas eu tellement
fayyad quelconque regret parce que sur
le boulevard c'est vrai qu'on a là haut
dit bertie jeunes et beckett afin de
tout c'est tous ces grands auteurs
ionesco ont été révélés par le boulevard
et pas par la fumée la codi française
n'a pas pour mission automatiquement de
révéler des auteurs c'est un c'est à la
fois amusé et une conservateur n'est pas
du grand le texte c'est à l'extérieur
que se crée vraiment l'alchimie le
travail en profondeur et ensuite comme
dit françaises cristallise tout ça et
rend en quelque sorte officiel le talent
et le génie de ses auteurs mais elle
fait également un travail de recherche
au niveau le tableau du petit théo dit
on par exemple de nombreuses pièces
montées chaque
jacques aubry qui ont révélé beaucoup de
jeunes auteurs est évident que là nous
avons fait des créations d'art ont tenté
cette année avec un bureau par exemple
avec félicité qui est qps qualité très
disputé mais qui était une pièce très
malade classe politique aux adultes et
et qui faisait bon a pu surprendre le
public traditionnel de la
comédie-française baisser ce public
traditionnel que nous voulons changer
essayer d'atteindre également un autre
public que celui des abonnés habillée
que nous avions qui sont laissons les
les mépriser pas du tout mais de donner
une possibilité un nouveau public de
venir à cette comédie française parce qu
il a été très difficile il était je dis
bien très difficile d'avoir des places
pour aller à la comédie française est
vrai toujours plein maintenant cela est
possible
il a volé soirée ouverte par exemple qui
permettent n'y a pas de location on peut
venir on peut obtenir des places à la
commune française qui était impossible
autrefois vrai alors c'est tout de même
une ouverture possible vers un futur
public et c'est cette mission-là
laquelle la commune française c'est ta
clé maintenant alors genre tu as joué
cette année à jouer l'école des femmes
tuent à partir avec ce spectacle
magnifique salon au canada au canada et
nous reprenons ensuite en septembre
octobre et je pense que le système par
exemple de l'alternance qui est aussi
une très importante à la comédie
française comme on part je trouve que
nous ne faisons pas assez mais c'est sur
des problèmes techniques très difficile
avec tous les techniciens ce sont des
problèmes difficiles à résoudre mais que
nous essayons de 2,2 de réaliser et il y
aura par exemple pour l'année prochaine
un nombre très important de création de
pièces nouvelles et de reprise qui vont
peut-être retrouver je pense cette
alternance qui était indispensable la
comédie française
j'ai vu aussi que fr3 puisque ça me sur
fr3 avait passé un contrat avec la
gaumont pour vos films et tout l'esprit
de molière il se trouve que comme l'a
fait en angleterre la bbc avec
shakespeare vous allez le faire vous
avec la cohérence je crois que ça c'est
une initiative de moati qui fait un
superbe travail avec jean pierre vincent
qui vont pouvoir justement présenter les
30 non pas les trente deux pièces de
molière tels qu'ils ont été annoncés
mais les 33 puisque c'est 33 pièces que
pierre a écrit
et que par conséquent tous ces
spectacles là vont pouvoir voir en
quelque sorte une une transmission de
tout le théâtre classique de molière qui
va pouvoir être amenées et pas au grand
public pour ceux qui ne pourront pas
venir la comédie française car il faut
pas penser comme il française est
uniquement fait pour paris ça a été
aussi son problème et sunrise je crois
que maintenant sa mission aussi c'est de
pouvoir aller à l'extérieur en province
et à l'étranger pour angers le cab est
avéré il y avait joué avec barreaux
renault et a besoin d'avoir une aide
indispensable nous allons en russie n'a
pas l'intention au mois d'octobre avec
et signe là nous avons continué
également tout le système des tournées
de présentation de spectacles à
l'étranger et en france c'est que la
comédie française il faut bien le dire
trot fois ne faisait pas là sa demande
évidemment non seulement un grand
travail parce que le système de troupes
et des distributions beaucoup de moyens
et las de ce côté là mon dieu nous ne
sommes pas aussi bien servi que nous
l'étions autrefois quand tu vas partir
aussi avait en la romaine à
vaison-la-romaine nous allons faire là
les joyeuses commères de windsor
effectivement le festival de vaison
l'arbalète un décor plus grand festival
de france où sont représentés les
joyeuses commères de windsor le 5 et le
6 août également à carcassonne le 31
juillet mais ça disons que ce sont des
vacances
[Musique]